I actually designed a hobbit board game
when I was probably eight years old in
my closet because I was slightly
embarrassed at the time and so I'd been
reading the hobbit and I think at the
time I was less interested in that it
was a game and I was more interested in
drawing the characters and sort of
imagining this incredible world that
I've been reading about so that was my
first game that I designed way back when
the first sort of digital game I
designed was really back in 2003 and it
was a game called a big urban game that
was commissioned by the Design Institute
in Minneapolis and it was a game that
used these giant inflatable game pieces
that people raced around the city over
the course of five days as a way to get
the the people of Minneapolis and st.
Paul to think about the design of their
city so that the digital component of
that game was a kind of website where
people called in and voted and so that
was really the first big game that I
designed
metropolis magazine which is a design
magazine was having a 25th anniversary
issue a couple years ago and they asked
myself and Franklin so I mentioned and
Nick for to know another game designer
in New York to develop a set of games
for the magazine and so we began to
think about well what what is an element
of games that if you modified it in a
way it could have a dramatic effect on
how you would think about games and so
we just picked the element of time we
thought well what if we moved away from
this notion and this was a this was in
you know mid 2000s when casual games
were really blossoming and so the whole
idea was people playing games and
snapped and snack like sizes so people
would have five minutes they could play
a game they would have a minute and so
game design became about shortening the
time it would take to play what happened
if we in long gated that notion of time
and it was a game that might take 25
years to play what would what would that
game look like what would that
experience of play look like how would
it change your relationship to the game
and slow so the notion of slow games
evolved out of that idea so we had one
game that was called I think it's called
the last facts and so the whole game was
to be the last person in the world to
send a fax we had a game that we
registered a product barcode in advance
of something ever being invented and the
person that invented the invention or
product that got to use that barcode
would win the game so there was no sense
of when that barcode might come up in
the queue of inventions there was a kind
of crossword puzzle game where there was
one clue a year that was given and that
it took 25 years to complete the game
and then there was a game that had a
drawing of I think it was a donkey that
had headphones on and had some kind of
crazy backpack and the idea was that you
would take a piece of paper with that
drawing on it and you would look at it
and then he would put it away and once a
year once a year you would take out the
folded piece of paper and you would win
the game if you had forgotten
what was on the piece of paper so we
were working with the idea of sort of
memory there that they're always these
artifacts that are kind of laying around
your house and could you cultivate a
game that where the goal is to not
remember a game piece rather than
remembering what the what the kind of
answer was
we are and there are very very few
people that are still playing them they
were really conceptual exercises and not
so much intended intended to be played
but the facts game still goes on facts
as a particularly in the real estate
very popular and the product code hasn't
been used yet so that game is still open